hey everybody welcome back to fantasy
valley i know i haven't uploaded too
many videos of this series recently and
I'm sorry about that I'll explain in a
little bit why that is but first I want
to very quickly say what I'm gonna do in
this video I'm gonna make a couple of
buildings home with a bunch of scenery
which is kind of more of the same but
I'll want to add a bit more detail to it
than the previous buildings yes I
actually do and try some other
variations of roofs and details and see
how all of that works out but first you
know before I start explaining things
while we going on I want to very quickly
say that I'm sorry about the upload rate
recently I do hope to make it a bit
better than one video a week or less
which it has been recently it is that
school has been killing me and I haven't
really fine found too many more good
opportunities to record some episodes
especially since some of these can take
quite a long time to make so basically I
have this one weekend where I've been
able to record two videos that's good we
pretty much got a good stache I guess
for one week to keep going but I do hope
to make more videos hopefully to a week
but I don't wanna keep it too strict to
schedule obviously since making videos
isn't my number one priority or number
one priority as Russian hacker would say
but yeah that's basically about that
upload rate should be getting a little
bit better but don't expect anything
really great because it's not summer
vacation anymore anyway into what I'm
gonna be building in this video we have
this one area right here which sits
right behind the coaster and you can see
the big plane of sand in the background
which is going to be the Arabian area
and basically what I want to do with
this area is get a row of buildings in
for two reasons for one because
hopefully it should look pretty good and
provide a nice backdrop for the rest of
the area kind of setting the scene and
making sure that the Asian area is one
nice coherent nicely themed area and
also because it kind of has the
functional purpose of making a port
between Arabia and the Far East of Asia
and I'm not really sure how well that's
going to work out it's going to be a
pretty well it's going to be a very
small border and the Arabian as area as
you can see is going to be very tight
it's not going to be as large as this
area is and I'm not really too sure how
this border is going to work out but
what I do know is that I need one large
building over here with the Asian Posada
on this side to set the scene here and
on the other side the Arabian facades to
make sure that it fits into that theme
but as you might be able to see there is
also going to be a path which leads
straight through that border into the
Arabian area and make sure that both
parts are connected and this was kind of
a challenge I wasn't really too sure
what to do with this because I need some
kind of gate to make sure that you're
still in Asia if you look from this
point but also to make sure that if
you're in Arabia you don't actually see
the rest of Asia you don't see big
towers or a big gate in the middle of
Arabia and for that to actually happen I
had to get a gate into both areas which
would look good from both angles but
also make sure that both other areas
aren't too visible if you're standing in
Arabia or Asia and that is what I'm
trying right here and there's a bunch of
different details to come along with it
this is one of the biggest kind of
criticisms that I had on myself was that
there wasn't really a great deal of
different details and different
texturing in the Asian area so far much
of it has just been using the very
simple wooden textures which is one
problem I wanted to get a bigger variety
of different colors and textures in here
just to make buildings look more
interesting and make the details pop out
a little bit more but also I had the
roof sets which I made for all of the
Asian buildings and I'm still going to
use that set for pretty much all the
buildings because I don't really have
anything else in a game which doesn't
have an Asian theme yet
but the problem with that was that many
of these roofs do tend to look pretty
much the same because they are all just
clones and after a while if you use them
for every single building you like the
variation which you want to see in real
buildings and for that to actually
happen I am hoping to make a couple of
different more unique slight alterations
to the roofs for each of the buildings
and this is kind of my start to doing so
as you can see on the roofs that I've
already got which are more steep and
have these different decorations on them
so I really won't be making new roofs
from scratch for each of the buildings
but I will be adding different kinds of
details to slightly change the shape or
slightly change what kind of ornaments I
have around the roofs so that's what I
want to play with a little bit more in
the future and another thing was the
texturing a way that I also wanted to do
that is stop using just the same wooden
posts every damn time and start using
some different texture and some
different textures wherever it was
possible so for instance for the bottom
of this building or for the different
balconies you have this very in light
which I haven't really used much before
but it's actually a pretty good texture
and works quite well with different
textures actually find especially for
wood if you're using different kinds of
textures within a building it starts
usually looking better and more
interesting which is why I wanted to go
for this kind of combination here now
the building itself in terms of the way
that it's built up is actually inspired
by some concept parts which I would
really usually do and also it's way too
heavily inspired I'll almost say that
some pieces are just straight ripped out
of it which you'll see in a bit but um
what's kind of special about that is
that usually I was a little bit too
uptight about doing unrealistic things
and mostly just used some real-life
examples as references for knowing how
certain roofs are made or
how you can realistically play certain
details and make certain buildings but
in this case I'm going for a fantasy
park and some people very rightly point
out I should be less uptight about
actually getting everything to be
realistic and just have fun with all
kinds of different ways of making
buildings and that is what I hope to do
a bit more so you'll see more of a mix
between Japanese and Asian kind of
buildings in this sense but also the
things that I'm basing on I'm kind of
throwing away all of the reference
pictures of real-life buildings and
forgetting about what exactly has to be
done in a certain way to make things
realistic and you know instead of doing
that just have fun with things and
experiment a bit more and do some more
weird stuff but also I am as a kind of
change I want to get some concept arts
as inspiration just to kind of see in
what ways you can do some ridiculous
stuff with Asian elements and there was
this one arts which was like it was an
arch or not exactly it was a it was two
bridges on both sides with an arch in
the middle to make a really big gate
into an area and I felt that was
something really good but of course it
was kind of already taken by that piece
of concept art so I wanted to make a
gate and make something similar to it
and ended up making something really bad
even if it was unique and scrapping that
and instead of doing that just going
straight for what the inspiration was
doing which was getting two bridges on
both sides with an arch in the middle so
that's what we're going for here with a
bunch of different details that which is
kind of messing with whatever would look
good but that's the basic make up of
this gate which divides the two areas we
have the towers on the side the bridge
which really makes it into an arch and
something that goes over the path but it
doesn't actually connect on either side
instead we have the big ornamental part
in the middle of it which connects the
two bridges and makes the entire
building finished and this is basically
the gates into the Arabian area
it still is a very Japanese building it
uses black roofs and it doesn't actually
paint the wood which is one of the
biggest differences between Japanese and
Chinese architecture is that usually
Japanese buildings don't actually paint
the exterior which Chinese buildings
really like to do so in this case it's a
bit more Japanese but still it has more
kinds of details it's a way less common
kind of building and especially in the
placement which is which it is in right
now and what the entire row of buildings
on this side of the coaster is going to
look like I wouldn't call it realistic
in the end but that's what we're going
for
so I should just relax once anyway
moving on to the second building which
is the much more Chinese inspired
building and a small experiment on
trying out different kinds of groups and
windows and things which is quite fun it
is a mostly red building with a lot of
different details on it but shape wise
it's not actually to importance or
interesting it's pretty much just a
rectangle that is made interesting by
all of the details around it so I
wouldn't get two doors on the front
which are just kind of simple decorated
doors but hopefully with the color
choices and the rest of the building
kind of context will look Asian enough
and for the rest of the walls will be
going with some different kinds of
windows and the thing that I was kind of
testing out here is the many decorations
that you have on walls and on windows on
these kinds of buildings there isn't any
kind of Asian war in the game but what
you do see on many of these Asian walls
are so many paintings or frames or like
decorative patterns on all of them on
all of the walls and there is no other
way to really make this than to put a
bunch of different details which are not
meant to be used for this kind of thing
together to somehow get some interesting
patterns and colors into the walls and
that's what this building was mostly an
experiment for trying to see how you can
put these different kinds of pieces
together to make these patterns on the
walls and
quite happy with how it turned out and
also with the color palette of the
building in a sense since the building
uses red details and red roofs which I
would usually kind of avoid usually the
very quick and sure way to make the
color scheme of a building work out is
to have one color for the walls one
color for the details and one for the
roof but for this building pretty much
everything is red except with some of
the things that cannot be read or
shouldn't probably be read to at least
tell what things are but there's a lot
of red on this building but I'm still
quite happy with how it works out and
one of the reasons why I think it worked
out in the end is because you've got all
of these golden details that pop out of
it with a very vertical and not so Asian
things on the front of it but which work
outs to get some different colors and
different kinds of shapes into the
building and make that rectangular box
still interesting to look while it still
kind of fits into the rest of the
facades so there's that building but
we're already working on the next
building for quite a while here this
final building is again very Japanese as
opposed to the last very Chinese
building and it's really inspired by
typical Japanese houses that you see
quite a lot we've got a large Japanese
gable roof as the main section and a
smaller roof right next to it as a
slightly smaller and way to bring out
the building a little bit more and
that's really the very simple set up
there are many houses that have this
kind of setup but obviously since it's a
really simple setup I wanted to mess
with the details of the building a
little bit more so again adding a super
large vertical accent which no Asian
building would realistically add but it
looks kind of all right so I figured it
would be pretty cool especially fitting
it in with the golden details on the
building right next to it and a bunch of
different wood textures to make the
different shapes and also this is going
to be the toilet building I have no idea
why but this also seemed like a very
toilet building looking building so I
put some toilets in it to actually give
this facade some kind of use as well the
other buildings don't really have use
since I didn't
really find any way to connect them to
the path there's going to be a staircase
in front of the rent building and the
two towers have like Castle war pieces
on the bottom of them which kind of
sloped down and there's no way to
actually put any kind of facilities in
them that guests would be able to reach
so this is really the best building to
do this kind of thing in and I don't
have many toilets so far and toilets are
of course some of the most fun thing to
build in this game so I'm going for some
toilet here and just to add a bunch of
ridiculous unnecessary details that are
still pretty fun to make a small arch on
the front with a decoration which right
now it doesn't actually have anything
but at some later point I realized that
that was the perfect place to put the
toilet sign so we're gonna have a toilet
sign in the future right there and also
I painted some of the planks on the
walls which you wouldn't really see in
this kind of Japanese building either
but I kind of dig it gives some color
into the otherwise just brown and black
building some kind happy with how that
turn out and bunch of doors actually get
some patterns and different colors into
the walls as well so it's shaping up
pretty nicely at this point I just
needed to fill in all of the different
roofs and the different art all of the
different windows and the different
doors and that is what I did a bunch of
experimentation with her I eventually
just settled making most of these
windows myself the reason why I was
really hesitating to do this kind of
thing is that it's very heavy on the
Polly's and this park is already quite a
bit more heavy on the police than I
would like it to be it is actually
already dipping into twenty FPS which is
starting to worry me
I felt I was very safe before I went
into the Asian area but then it turned
out that the roofs for the Asian area or
as much of a problem as I expected it to
be
I was definitely hoping to be able to
finish the rest of the part given by how
much the Main Street removed FPS but the
Asian area in particular is probably
going to be by far the luckiest part of
the park but yeah that's just a very
quick side note I'm not going to worry
about that too much until it's actually
going to be a problem but yeah I wanted
to stay away from like custom-made
windows for that kind of reason but in
the end they just kind of looked too
good to avoid them so I made a few
windows for this building as well and
why I am super happy with how they look
it does kind of make me sad because
that's probably another frame gone for
the rest of my life and we'll have to
see how to actually make this work in
the end anyway
last thing that I wanted to do because
the buildings are pretty much finished
at this point is at a bunch of paths
work stuff along the path here the path
itself is very narrow but I wanted to
make sure that this area is large enough
to actually give you a good panorama of
what this entire area is going to look
like but also on the other side of this
pond I'm going to have a tea house which
is going to be a disguised chief beef
burger place which is kind of shame
because these houses are like super posh
and everything but um yeah that's got to
be a pretty important restaurant and
unlike Stu have like some seating areas
where you can actually sit down and eat
your burgers as you look over the water
because this is probably one of the best
views in the park and I definitely want
to make use of that view and put a
restaurant in here so we're going to
have a bunch of tables and like some
terraces on this side of the pond and I
needed to open up the path work quite a
bit to actually allow that which is why
we're having this very wide thing here
anyway you're going to see that in the
next episode so thank you guys for
watching this one and hope to see you
guys later
[Music]